♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
ONE OF THE REASONS MOST OF THE
WESTERN WORLD EMBRACED
UNPRECEDENTED TO MASK
QUARANTINES THIS SPRING WAS DUE
TO THE WORK OF A SINGLE MAN, A
MAN YOU MAY NOT HAVE HEARD OF.
A BRITISH ACADEMIC CALLED NEIL
FERGUSON, HE’S A PROFESSOR AT A
COLLEGE IN LONDON BUT HE’S ALSO
SOMETHING OF AN INTERNATIONAL
CELEBRITY, BEST KNOWN FOR HIS
DIRE PREDICTIONS ABOUT
PANDEMICS.
HE SEEMED ESPECIALLY PANICKED BY
THE WUHAN CORONAVIRUS.
AT ONE POINT HE SUGGESTED THE
CORONAVIRUS MIGHT BE COMPARABLE
TO THE SPANISH FLU OF 1918, THE
PANDEMIC THAT KILLED UP TO
100 MILLION PEOPLE.
ON FEBRUARY 28TH AS THE DISEASE
IS SPREAD THROUGH EUROPE, HE
PUBLICLY ENDORSED THE CHINESE
MODEL OF QUARANTINE,
SPECIFICALLY.
KEEP IN MIND AS HE SPOKE THE
WORDS ARE ABOUT TO SEEK AND THE
VIDEOS WERE CIRCULATING ON THE
INTERNET SHOWING POLICE IN WUHAN
THROWING SCREAMING CITIZENS INTO
THE BACK OF PANEL TRUCKS AND
DRIVING THEM TO SOME UNSPECIFIED
INTERNMENT SOMEWHERE.
FERGUSON MUST HAVE KNOWN THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE IN
WUHAN WAS EXTREME AND UTTERLY
INHUMANE, HE ENDORSED IT ANYWAY.
THAT’S HOW SERIOUS HE WAS ABOUT
THIS VIRUS.
>> ONE HAS TO ADOPT COMMUNITY
MEASURES WHICH HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
PARTICULARLY IN PLACES LIKE
WUHAN IN CHINA WHERE YOU HAVE TO
REDUCE CONTACTS BETWEEN PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY, SORTS OF
MEASURES ARE IMPORTANT.
IF ANYBODY HAS ANY SORT OF
RESPIRATORY DISEASE, THEY HAVE
TO STAY AT HOME UNTIL THEIR
SYMPTOMS ARE FULLY RESOLVED.
>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKE KIND OF
A RESERVED ACADEMIC AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN HE’S ENDORSING THE WUHAN
RESPONSE.
LEADERS AROUND THE WORLD PAID
ATTENTION TO THIS, THEY TOOK HIS
ADVICE AND LOCKED DOWN THEIR
ENTIRE POPULATIONS, THE BRITISH
GOVERNMENT ASKED FERGUSON TO
HELP DESIGN IS QUARANTINE AS A
MEMBER OF THE SCIENTIFIC
ADVISORY GROUP FOR EMERGENCY.
HE WAS HAPPY TO HELP SHUT DOWN
THE ENTIRE UNITED KINGDOM BUT IT
TURNS OUT HE WASN’T THAT
INTERESTED AT ALL IN
PARTICIPATING IT PERSONALLY.
THE TELEGRAPH REPORTED HE
IGNORED HIS OWN LOCK DOWNS WHILE
THE REST OF LONDON STAY TRAPPED
INDOORS, FERGUS HE REPEATEDLY
INVITED HIS MARRIED MISTRESS
OVER TO HIS APARTMENT FOR SEX
AND MOST STRIKING OF ALL, HE WAS
INFECTED WITH THE CORONAVIRUS AT
THE TIME.
HE BECAME SICK AND TESTED
POSITIVE IN MID-MARCH, HE SAID
SO PUBLICLY AT THE TIME.
NOT LONG AFTER THAT HE INVITED
HIS MISTRESS OVER.
BY DOING THIS, HE EXPOSED HER TO
A DEADLY VIRUS, HE ALSO EXPOSED
HER HUSBAND AND HER CHILDREN
BACK HOME.
WHEN CONFRONTED THE DAY, HE SAID
THIS.
"I ACTED IN THE BELIEF THAT I
WAS IMMUNE, THAT WAS HIS
EXPLANATION.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE IS NO
SCIENTIFIC PROOF THAT THAT’S
TRUE, CAN SOMEONE WHO WAS SICK A
FEW WEEKS AGO STILL TRANSMIT THE
CORONAVIRUS?
WE ARE NOT SURE.
FOR A FAMOUS SCIENTIST, NEIL
FERGUSON IS CURIOUSLY IGNORANT
OF SCIENCE.
HE’S ALSO OBVIOUSLY UNAPPALLING
HYPOCRITE AND HE’S NOT ALONE IN
THAT.
SO MANY OF THE PEOPLE MAKING OUR
POLICIES ARE LIKE THIS, ALMOST
COMPULSIVELY AGAIN AND AGAIN
THEY DO THE VERY THINGS THEY
PUNISH US FOR DOING.
WHEN THEY ARE CAUGHT, THEY
ACKNOWLEDGE NO SHAME, THEY ARE
ENTIRELY LACKING IN
SELF-AWARENESS, THEY DISCREDIT
THEMSELVES WITHOUT EVEN
REALIZING IT.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY AFTER TELLING
THE REST OF NEW YORK CITY TO
STAY INSIDE,
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO LOADED UP
HIS SUV WITH GOVERNMENT
BODYGUARDS AND HEADED TO THE GYM
ACROSS TOWN IN BROOKLYN, A
GOVERNMENT SPOKESMAN LATER
EXPLAIN THE TRIP WAS NECESSARY
BECAUSE HIS JIM HAS BEEN A HUGE
PART OF HIS AND HIS FAMILY’S
LIFE.
de BLASIO LIKES HIS JIM SO HE
KEPT GOING THERE DESPITE TELLING
YOU NOT TO.
GOT IT.
WEEKS LATER, HE STILL COULDN’T
STAY OUT OF BROOKLYN, ONE DAY HE
AND HIS WIFE LEFT HOME IN
MANHATTAN AND DROVE MORE THAN 10
SOME SUNSHINE AND FRESH AIR.
BASED ON THE CITIZEN HAPPEN TO
SEE THE WHOLE THING AND
VIDEOTAPE IT.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE A PART, YOU
LIVE IN THE MIDDLE OF A PARK,
YOU DON’T NEED TO TRAVEL TO
BROOKLYN.
YOU WON’T EVEN OPEN ROADS FOR
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS.
I’M NOT GOING TO GIVE IT A
BREAK, THIS IS SELFISH BEHAVIOR,
THIS IS THAT THE UP ENEMY OF
NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL.
>> Tucker: NONESSENTIAL
TRAVEL, WHAT’S THAT?
WHEN YOU MAKE THE RULES, THAT’S
NOT EVEN A CATEGORY.
JUST ASK JUSTIN TRUDEAU, THE
PREACHY PRIME MINISTER OF
CANADA.
ON APRIL 12, HE RELEASED A VIDEO
COMMANDING CANADIANS TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES FOR EASTER, IT’S
WHAT WOULD DO HE DECLARED.
>> AS WE REFLECT ON’S MESSAGE OF
LOVE AND COMPASSION, LET’S THINK
ABOUT OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND ESSENTIAL SERVICE WORKERS
WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES EVERY
DAY, PUTTING INTO PRACTICE WHAT
IT TRULY MEANS TO LOVE OUR
NEIGHBORS AS OURSELVES BY MAKING
SACRIFICES TO PROTECT THEIR
HEALTH.
LET’S STAY HOME FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: THAT’S THE KIND OF
QUARANTINE ENDORSES, LOVE MEANS
STAYING HOME.
FOR YOU, NOT FOR THEM.
NOT LONG AFTER RECORDING THE
VIDEO YOU JUST SAW, HE LEFT THE
CAPITOL AND TRAVELED ALL THE WAY
TO QUEBEC TO VISIT HIS FAMILY AT
THEIR LAKE HOUSE, JUST LIKE YOU
WOULD WANT TO DO ON EASTER IF
YOU WERE ALLOWED TO DO THAT BUT
YOU’RE NOT ALLOWED, SO STOP
COMPLAINING.
YOU MIGHT ALSO WANT TO GET YOUR
HAIR CUT AND IN CHICAGO LAST
MONTH, THAT WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
COME YOU CAN GET YOUR HAIR CUT
UP AT THE CITY’S MAYOR
LORI LIGHTFOOT HAD HER HAIR DONE
ANYWAY -- WHEN SHE WAS CAUGHT
DOING THIS, SHE DIDN’T EVEN
BLUSH.
WE PLAYED THIS CLIP FOR YOU ON
FRIDAY’S SHOW BUT IT’S ONE OF
THOSE VIDEOS NO MATTER HOW MANY
TIMES YOU WATCH IT IT DROPS YOUR
JAW EVERY TIME.
>> ON THE PUBLIC FACE OF THIS
CITY, I’M ON NATIONAL MEDIA AND
I’M OUT IN THE PUBLIC EYE.
A PERSON -- I TAKE MY PERSONAL
HYGIENE VERY SERIOUSLY.
I FELT LIKE I NEEDED TO HAVE A
HAIRCUT, I’M NOT ABLE TO DO THAT
MYSELF AND SO I GOT A HAIRCUT.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
SHUT UP, PAROLES -- I’M ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION.
CHRIS CUOMO KNOWS THAT FEELING
VERY WELL.
LAST MONTH HE DROVE TO A PIECE
OF PROPERTY HE OWNS IN THE
HAMPTONS WERE APPARENTLY HE’S
BUILDING A NEW WEEKEND HOUSE.
AT THAT TIME, HE WAS INFECTED
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS AND
SUFFERING FROM SYMPTOMS.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
QUARANTINED IN TOTAL ISOLATION
IN HIS BASEMENT FULL TIME,
THAT’S WHAT HE TOLD HIS
TELEVISION AUDIENCE HE WAS.
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT, HE PUT ON
SHOWS THAT REVOLVES AROUND HIS
STRUGGLES WITH THE ILLNESS IN
HIS VIRTUOUS AND EVEN SELFLESS
EFFORTS TO PREVENT OTHERS FROM
GETTING INFECTED WITH IT.
GIVEN ALL THE PUBLICITY HE
GENERATED FOR BEING SICK AT
LEAST ONE HAMPTONS RESIDENT WAS
SHOCKED TO SEE HIM OUT AND ABOUT
AND CONFRONTED HIM ABOUT IT.
HE RESPONDED BY CALLING THE MAN
A LOSER, THE MAN’S REAL NAME IS
DAVID WHALEN AND WE INVITED HIM
ON THE SHOW.
>> I JUST SAID DON’T YOU HAVE
THE CORONAVIRUS?
ACTION TO BE QUARANTINED?
I THINK HIS NEXT WORDS WERE
"WHAT THE HELL DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
THIS, WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
RULES AND I SAID YOU’RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE OUT HERE --
NOBODY HAD GLOVES ON, NOBODY HAD
MASKS ON.
>> Tucker: DID YOU HEAR THAT
DETAIL?
NO GLOVES, NO MASKS.
UNINFECTED MAN CIRCULATING AMONG
AN UNSUSPECTED POPULATION.
WHEN YOU WATCH TELEVISION YOU
IMAGINE HE’S A RESPONSIBLE
JOURNALIST, THAT’S HOW HE
DESCRIBES HIMSELF.
IN FACT, HE’S TYPHOID MARY AND
THERE’S A VAST GAP BETWEEN THOSE
TWO PERSONAS.
FOR THE AVERAGE PERSON HYPOCRISY
IS THE MOST EMBARRASSING THING
OF ALL, GETTING CAUGHT THE WAY
HE DID WOULD SPUR A NEXUS MENTAL
CRISIS AND MOST PEOPLE, YOU
MIGHT DECIDE TO DEVOTE THE REST
OF YOUR LIFE TO PERSONAL
HUMILITY AND IN RESPONSE.
CHRIS CUOMO DIDN’T LOOK BACK, HE
BLAMED THE OTHER GUY AND KEPT
GOING, HE WAS RIGHT THERE ON
TELEVISION JUST LAST NIGHT
HARANGUING PEOPLE FOR DOING
PRECISELY WHAT HE DID.
>> OTHERS ALSO FEEL MY FATIGUE.
I’VE HAD IT, THE SEASON IS
CHANGING, IT’S GETTING WARM, I
WANT TO GET BACK TO IT, LOOK AT
THESE FOOLS, FOOLS!
I KNOW THEY WANT TO BE OUT
THERE, IT’S NOT ABOUT YOU.
WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER PEOPLE?
I’M NOT GOING TO CASTIGATE YOU,
THAT’S NOT MY JOB, I’M NOT YOUR
DADDY.
>> Tucker: FOOLS!
IT’S NOT ABOUT YOU SAYS THE BUFF
CNN ANCHOR, BECAUSE IF THERE’S
ONE THING IN THIS WORLD THAT
CHRIS CUOMO CAN’T STAND, IT’S
NARCISSISM, HE HATES IT.
IT DOESN’T SEEM TO OCCUR TO QUIZ
CUOMO FOR A MOMENT THAT HE MAY
BE DESCRIBING HIMSELF, IT NEVER
OCCURS TO ANY OF THESE PEOPLE.
IT’S NEVER ONE TIME OCCURRED TO
CHRIS CUOMO’S BROTHER THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK, NEW YORK,
ANDREW CUOMO GAVE A PUNGENT
PRESS BRIEFING AS HE SO OFTEN
DOES.
WATCH THIS CLIP AND TELL US WHAT
YOU NOTICE.
>> I THINK IT’S DISRESPECTFUL OF
PEOPLE NOT TO WEAR MASKS.
THINK ABOUT IT, DO I THINK LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE ENFORCING
IT AND SHOULD THEY BE SANCTIONS?
YES BECAUSE IT’S A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A PENALTY.
BECAUSE YOU COULD LITERALLY KILL
SOMEONE.
YOU COULD LITERALLY KILL SOMEONE
BECAUSE YOU DIDN’T WANT TO WEAR
A MASK.
>> Tucker: HERE THAT?
IT’S DISRESPECTFUL, YOU COULD
LITERALLY KILL SOMEONE BY NOT
WEARING A MASK SAYS THE MAN NOT
WEARING A MASK WHO HAPPENS TO BE
SITTING NEXT TO OTHER PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT WEARING MASKS.
DO THEY HEAR THEMSELVES WHEN
THEY TALK LIKE THIS?
ON SOME LEVEL THEY DO, THEY KNOW
THEY ARE HYPOCRITICAL FRAUDS AND
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY LECTURE
YOU SO HYSTERICALLY, IT MAKES
THEM FEEL BETTER.
THEY PROBABLY SUSPECT YOU KNOW
WHAT TOO, THEY SIMPLY DON’T CARE
ENOUGH ABOUT YOUR OPINION TO
BOTHER WITH WHAT YOU THINK.
THAT’S ALL OF THEM.
THIS WOULD BE INFURIATING IF